and WTF news what the [ __ ] Wednesday
Thursday Friday yeah that seven that's
what I meant
submitted by my my my my my you know my
mind may be may maybe there's a Chinese
person an accused cop killer folks Oh
halted jury selection for his trial by
rubbing feces on his face his head yeah
I just took it huh pcs I think it would
be like crazy if it was someone else's
feces if its own it's played out you
gonna have to see from yourself I'm
asking you yeah uncle matter you're
gonna have to have to see I don't know
how to see might be the sex one or I
think it's Hep B Hep B as the poop one
why don't you get pinkeye
hey is it you get diarrhea from eating
diarrhea I think so I think so
yeah reproduces itself why cuz you
pictured yourself eating day round
myself a pictured him eating it why'd
you go there I pictured myself eating
diarrhea you're better than I am Oh get
that viagra sorry I was a throwback to a
lot besides episode the Agra or wait for
it yeah so anyways this guy here he was
Travis 35 years old he was charged with
killing a New Orleans police officer
while escaping custody in 2015 oh no so
he was initially arrested because he
fired a gun shot near his wife his own
wife and then when he was placed on the
back of a patrol car he somehow still
had the gun on him and oh come on Coco
then he shot the cop he squeezed through
the front and the police officer he was
trying to fight with him like to keep
him in the car but then he was weakened
by the gunshot and then he ended up
escaping through the front kind of
police cars the front and why did the
cop not pat him down all kinds of [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
right now unless that cop was like just
really dumb he's like give me this gun
and Pat's him down clear I hope that's
not the case
rest in peace officer so in the jury in
the in the court of law that's when he
wiped that [ __ ] all over himself yeah so
this is how come on picture like a big
brown marker and he's just like yeah
like a solid poop that's better than
what I pick which it picks like a glob
yeah yeah I'm just squatting and then
just [ __ ] getting in just doing this
thing but like kind of wore pants
picture my poop from last night and it
was nice and solid I wouldn't be able to
do that like even if I got to that point
right just [ __ ] in my head I would I
can't do this yeah no he's still saying
he's felt when it went to his mouth he
went I don't think I've been saying I
won't go to the death chamber
that's probably why he did it
just look at how crazy I am is this
crazy enough for you yeah I got the
crazy initial thing here so then he
accelerated the cop car and crashed into
a pole and then the blew out the window
get a roll because he had lost his motor
skill so he just ended up crashing and
he passed away got all those poles then
stops cars Travis what thank God for the
poles yeah so then Travis ended up
escaping but he was captured the next
day and then so now at the murder trial
proceedings they're set to begin and
then the jury selection was taking place
when all of a sudden he Travis he pulls
out of his pocket who and he put in this
bog in a napkin yes it you poop in a
napkin and then he doesn't he like
handcuffed that's healthy
well it's during the the
trial he still cuffed so I guess he just
had it there that's healthy that he had
a solid poop yeah I just said it was a I
know what my [ __ ] looks like and it's
not always solid so then that's not my
counter napkin not all the time that
could have been like a tootsie roll just
just not solid you better get that
checked I know that's what I'm saying
it's probably milk products maybe you
want to stay away from that because it's
your body's not producing that lactose I
don't really drink that much you know he
also need maybe some more vegetables Oh
fiber fine what do you need that's
what's this maybe this point she
probably have a lot of fiber that's what
her purpose well do you eat a lot of
protein without fiber then it's runny
smiley hard but sometimes it smells like
burnt rubber at a NASCAR track you know
his poop is occasionally occasionally it
doesn't I think it's because I've had
too much gluten oh I think so I'm not a
scientist
you know I think glutens a white person
thing I'm not too sure it sounds like
yet too much pepperidge farm
it's cookies fool the poop in the napkin
without saying a word he starts smearing
it all over his face head and mouth okay
and then sounds like a poopoo party so
they're assuming that he collected this
during one of the restroom breaks
obviously I literally would I just as a
child I was like well death [ __ ] on
yourself what are you doing well the
judge ended up ordering an immediate
halt to the proceedings he dismissed the
jury panel and ordered a new competency
evaluation on Travis but previously to
this trial he had already been deemed
competent to stand trial well he is
competent because he put it in a napkin
which means he cared that it was gonna
stain his brand-new [ __ ] orange
clothes yeah what he should have done
was i hungry Your Honor I'm not guilty
yeah cuz I thought she [ __ ] there and he
grabbed it but he put it in a napkin
like you save a sandwich or a
lighten [ __ ] grandma that puts the
cookies in a napkin for you later this
is for me got a nice mouth for some
reason picture the Puerto Rican man it's
got a nice lips it's a shame you put
[ __ ] on them he's gonna be in the mental
hospital until his trial of resuming
they also didn't take away his necklace
yeah they let him keep his no I lose
focus how come he gets to wears orange
suit like with so much good swag get the
police protocol this C is just crazy he
says like please kill this [ __ ]
please he's talking from I almost be
conservatively for a second because I
most of my issue I think liberally a lot
you know I the death penalty
kind of like rings the bell people like
I don't know but with me I'm sort of
like man you kill my family you kill and
you kill someone and it's obvious
there's no like there's no debate you
killed this person then they say I'm
clinically insane yet you have to be to
kill someone why do we keep these people
around there's no reason they spend
hundreds of millions of dollars you just
earned yourself citizenship in my
Ignatian of that you know you're you're
totally yes that's a hundred percent
awesome you kill a man any woman baby
anything you kill someone and someone
there's video of you doing it or you
there's no why are we wasting money on
these people this guy's eating [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] he killed a man with a family
I'm [ __ ] killing you less than human
why should people treat you as human
don't we have enough people in the world
don't we have enough you gotta catch him
up with Jamal and think he message Imam
but see here's the weird thing
I would kill him for putting [ __ ] on his
face alone I wasn't even thinking about
the murder part I was like either either
[ __ ] face are you still up so the [ __ ]
face honestly it could be corrected I
didn't kill anybody just smeared [ __ ] on
maybe there isn't no he made me spell it
in court he needs dying well that might
be quite muddy I'm not a part of the law
so there's a reason that's North Korean
politics right over here
I'm like two percent North Korean I
think it's just well you're welcome to
my nation anytime I have a country
called Joe Mallya it's a utopian society
of Gemara yeah it's a beautiful place
where we all have roles in it too what
do you do I don't know what am i good
you're the hits mirror you're supposed
to be like the the secretary of babies
where your sole job is to what do you
call it the Pediatrics department and
all that we haven't figured out this
country - it just keeps changing because
it's like you know like a small town
word you know everyone wears different
but in this world you believe in killing
some we believe in I for an I like
literally live in this case - literally
the guy shot at his wife right and then
it wasn't it so that's understanding was
in the bed of course I mean she could
have been gone off on it I'm kidding and
so what happened was he's in the back of
the car and he decides to kill this
officer for no [ __ ] reason
literally for no [ __ ] reason he
Wiggles through the little hole like an
octopus have you seen those videos oh
yeah they could get through anything
well he gets his ass outside I just
don't know why there's so many bad
people in the world I mean just keep him
around it's like ma'am I can't kill
anybody just because he killed someone
it makes that's worth know it doesn't
[ __ ] out of our [ __ ] world you kill
someone get out of here I don't want you
here thanks for watching guys and those
are our thoughts what are your thoughts
don't forget to comment below we want to
know what you guys are thinking but
don't write anything that will make it
sad or make us mad because after all
we're just kidding news and we're a very
happy channel for the last video click
up here
[Music]